it's uh still when it comes to the
tournament you still have destiny in
your own hands if you win the rest of
your matches you will win this
tournament is that is that a good
feeling to have after a bad day at work
yeah um
how about today i just i think the
second game was crucial and
um
i just missed that uh
after bishop has six that is king h5 i
just forgot that
h5 square exist
and
yeah it was kind of over pushed as damn
also said
so and this game i
i don't think i really played well um i
missed many things and
yeah uh the final thing was through k1
and after that the game was over um
about the standings yeah it's good still
to be uh i guess number two so yeah uh
still two more matches
and i want to give my best
prague good luck tomorrow on the bounce
back and liam
it is good luck on continuing this good
trend that you've developed yeah thank
you i mean every win here it really
means a lot and especially against um
prague when he's in farm he was has been
playing so well so we're very happy with
the result today and hopefully we
continue doing better
thank you
thanks